it's one of jodie foster's first big hit
Freaky Friday yeah this is just at the
time when the whole switching body and
mind things was kind of big and Disney
had to do their take on it too and for
what they did it's not bad the stories
about textbook is you can get a mother
and daughter don't get along and they're
constantly screaming at each other and
one day they say wouldn't it be great if
we switch places and you knew what was
like to be me well one day that's
exactly what happens they switch around
and sure enough they're stuck in each
other's bodies the daughter has to be
mother and the mother has to be daughter
as you imagine they're in way over their
head they have trouble making friends
and yeah they find out maybe it is hard
being this person the movie was a big
hit when it came out and yeah I can kind
of see why it is funny it is charming
both actresses do a good job
impersonating the other but there was a
part of me that feels it's just a little
too dated not to say that isn't funny at
times are really a lot of fun but I
don't know
don't you know exactly from the
beginning where this is gonna go and
don't you know half of these jokes that
are coming and I think with a story like
this that's been done so many times you
have to add a little bit more to it and
here I just don't see that much more
added again apart from two very fine
performances and sort of the standard
textbook stuff that you do with this
story but it's cute it's fun
like I said everybody acts well even if
it is over the top at times seeing them
interact in different environments while
still keeping that mindset is always
cute to see I don't know it just for me
I feel like nothing too much else is
added to it so I don't know the
incredible value of watching it except
maybe for the performances which are
funny but not phenomenal I don't even
know really what else to say about it
it's cute if you want to see a story
about a mother and a daughter who's
which places and they have to interact
it's fine I just wish they could have
added something a little bit more but
maybe that's not what it's supposed to
be maybe it's just supposed to be your
straightforward comedy with the
straightforward scenario and that's
pretty much what you get like I said not
too much a review because I just can't
think that much to say about it but if
you
into this kind of very basic story
you'll like it fine if you want
something a little bit more meaty well
maybe take a look at the remake yeah I
just said that you all know why go watch
the next video like to be you